lui dit tu me crois capable de ça au
revoir tu ne me mérites pas voilà mais
il est resté quand même he et 8 jours
après j'avais la bague au doigt al on
s'est marié en 53 ah il était brun
[Musique]
hein j'ai fait ma
médecine avec le mari de
ma de ma meilleure amie et un jour il m
dit
voilà on a un copain qu'on a connu
pendant la guerre il est à castre en ce
moment il vient à Toulouse et on va
faire une soirée est-ce que ça t'amuse
il assister chez cet ami nous avons
dîner ensemble et puis coup de foud je
je l'ai emmené au cinéma et non non non
on a dansé coup de foudre non après non
ça ah bah moi moi je l'ai eu là
F et je me suis laissé avoir et problème
on a lutté tous les deux contre ça parce
qu'on nait pas la même
religion moi j'étais une protestante de
vieille famille où mes ancêtres se sont
batttu
donc il fallait transmettre et mon mari
d'origine juive et il fallait
transmettre aussi voilà après plus
plusieurs discussions je lui dis mais
qu'est-ce que tu attends oui ou non et
il me répond j'ai cœur qu' qu'au cours
d'une dispute tu me traînes salu lu dit
tu me crois capable de ça au revoir tu
ne me mérites pas VO mais il est resté
quand même et 8 jours après j'avais la
bague au doigt à cet âge là est-ce que
vous vous disputez encore ben
heureusement
oui enfin nous dirons moins vous dire
queil n'y a jamais eu d'accro ni de
dispute heureusement d'ailleurs ça
serait mentir on na jamais consulté un
avocat voilà non jamais enfin moi à
titre personnel j'ai jamais envisager
une séparation quelle qu'elle soit on
s'est promis de jamais s'endormir fâché
alors on fait un petit baiser
quelquefois un peu nerveux
mais il a été donné et le lendemain ça
repart la dispute est-ce que vous pouvez
me dire si on a encore des rapports
sexuels à votre âge ou est-ce que ça
remonte d' a longtemps et est-ce qu'on y
pense encore V notre âge il y a quand
même un certain temps mais c'était non
mais on a des gestes très très
affectueux oui nous dirons que l'amour
s'est transformé en un grand une grande
affection et tendresse et tendresse et
en plus amitié voilà ça fait beaucoup de
choses qui reste mais et mettez des
point de suspension parce qu'on n pas
tout dit on est très gestuel oui gestuel
oui raison plus que beaucoup de gens
d'autreâge quand on restaurant il disent
pas un mot entre eux non non non ça nous
on a toujours quelque chose le drame ça
va être la
séparation marqu le contraire arriver
que que
le la liaison ne soit pas aussi bonne et
puis que on se
comprenne non non mais je dis non c'est
pas ça que je dis mal dit je dis pour
quelqu'un d'autre il y a deux
personnalités ça je ne pense pas qu'il
soit bon que qu' a qu'une seule
personnalité que on soit l'esclave de
l'un ou de
l'autre c'est pas du tout c'est pas du
prop ce qu'il a c'est qu'on a les même
réaction devant les problèmes devant
devant la culture devant
euh devant la vie euh ah devant les
sentiments aussi oui devant les
sentiments oui on a les mêmes réactions
ça c'est exact c'est ça sens des valeurs
c'est certainement voilà le sens des
valeurs moi j'ai pas naturel jaloux
j'aurais pu parce que quelque fois on
aessé me le
piquer mais je faisais confiance pour
nos 70 ans les enfants nous ont préparé
un mariage mais en vrai robe longue robe
de marié caméia dans les cheveux et
alors il nous a fait un discours est-ce
qu'on veut se remarier il nous a mis les
fait mettre l'alliance l'un à l'autre et
on a sorti on est sorti et tous les
petits enfants nous ont envoyé des
pétales de rose le plus gros compliment
qu'on a eu c'est de mon Petitfils qui
s'est marié et en disant on veut vivre
comme
vous